welcome to another edition of a beginner
breakdown I am your host Mike comer and
today we'll be going over games that the
teacher has played against the student
we are using a chess base 13 that's the
program you're using and I am playing
the black pieces in this game against
Christopher so there's four or five
decent ways you can start out a chess
game okay
efore the computer loves it
d4 it's pretty good a knight f3 not too
shabby
even a b3 it's okay
our c4 which is what my opponent plays
okay this is called the English opening
okay so there's a lot of different ways
black encounter it ee five is probably
the most popular you just bring your
night out to f6 and it can transpose
into a d4 opening whole point of e5 is
the stop T fourth but I decide I'm going
to challenge the center right away with
the move d5 so now the pawns are
attacking each other and and he takes
okay so when somebody takes your stuff
right you want to take it back okay so
Queen takes d5 okay so we got some
people taking notes today which is good
yeah and it's very exciting
okay so so now I took so now you want to
attack you want to get your Knights and
your bishops off the back row hopefully
with a purpose like he got the night off
the back row attacking my queen so now
my queen is attacked I must move it the
safest place for the Queen
back home that's where I put it okay so
now he gets his epon out developing the
bishop okay so now I want to get my
bishop out as well but by when I play g6
because if I play east six I will be
blocking in this bishop so it's always
good to have your pieces as mobile as
possible so now he kind of copies off of
me which is fine and so now when I put
my bishop on this long diagonal
it's called fianchetto okay it's Italian
for on the flank or on the side so now
he's on this long diagonal so now Knight
up and I make a big mistake here I play
my bishop which i think is good it's
called a pin so if this night would move
I would take his queen so this Knight is
in a pin okay but White has a very good
way to get out of this pin he should
play Queen to b3 attacking my be pawn so
whenever you move you know your Bishop
your your B or G pond will be undefended
so think about that okay but he didn't
play that he goes heads and and he plays
Bishop to g2 just continues his
development so now so now I play my
Queen up and you see how my Queen and
Bishop are on the same line the same
diagonal so now they're acting like a 12
point piece because my Bishop is worth
three when my queen is worth nine so
that when they're operating together you
know more power to you like you don't
think of chess as a team game but it's
the ultimate team game everybody needs
to help out each other to a formulate
and attack one guy in rare occasion
cannot do it himself so now white gets
castled so now I try to break up the the
castle alignment with Bishop h3 so do
you want to go to that other program
then Simon it's like one more - or one
more time Bishop g2 and now he plays so
now the computer program we're using is
Houdini so hopefully we won't have any
of the problems we had before although
we have already stumbled upon a problem
okay so a review of the game okay so now
Queen Bishop aiming at age three we're
trying to get rid of his Bishop who was
a big defender of this King and so he
plays Knight to attack our bishop now
he's got two players his Knight and
Bishop attacking my Bishop and I only
have one defender so I got to either
move the bishop or take his Bishop which
I do so Knight takes and now I play the
move e5 to stop the knight from coming
to the square so the more squares you
can control in your enemy's territory
the better okay I get the night out he
plays Knight to d5 see now he's just
coming into my territory with no clear
objective okay he should be thinking
about getting his Bishop out you know
maybe it's rook out or something but now
with this Knight out there what's he
doing nothing so I can just attack it
which I do Knight f6 so he takes with
check okay so so if I move my king he'll
take my if I move my King you'll take my
queen so I can just
take it back when somebody takes
something yours it's very important that
you take it back okay so f4 so he's
coming he's attacking my guy but as you
notice my pawn is defended by the bishop
and the night so I don't necessarily
have to take it so I can just castle to
safety so he takes my pawn so if you're
if you're like well it doesn't matter if
I take with the bishop or Knight
look at that it's very important look at
how this rook is actually coming down
and attacking my bishop now it was it's
called a discovered attack so if I take
with a knight bye-bye bishop so
obviously I take with the bishop yeah
okay so so now he puts his knight where
my bishop can take it
so whenever even if it's protected
whenever you put a piece where it can be
captured you know don't be shocked if
it's captured oh I didn't think it was
going to cope normally it's like come on
dude you put it where I could take it so
so don't be shocked okay all right but I
have better ideas okay so I'm going to
double on the D file notice like before
I was using with the Queen and Bishop as
a 12-point piece now I got the Queen and
the rook as 14-point piece Queen's worth
9 rook is worth 5 okay and we're coming
down and attacking this pawn so now he
plays Queen to b3 so now let me ask you
how many players are protecting the D
pawn here so we have the Queen and the
knight and how many attackers do I have
we have the Queen and the rook so we
have two attackers two Queen and rook
the rook is attacking the pawn through
an x-ray and then he's got two defenders
so an easy way to do that is is a tactic
called remove the defender
remove the guard so when we take the
night if we can which we can't okay we
take it and then he'll have to take back
one way or the other and so he'll take
back with the bishop here well he could
take back with the pawn but I guess he
wants to get his uh his Bishop out and
he probably doesn't want to if he takes
with the pawn he would be allowing a big
check possibly here too which I probably
would not give him but he would be
allowing it so when he takes back with
the bishop I can take this pawn now
because I have two players and he only
has the one so I was really expecting
him to come down and take here but when
he takes Queen takes d3 rook takes d3
and made it pretty easy for me and now
he wants to challenge the file you
really want the open files like you see
how this D file it's wide open okay so
so he challenges the file which is good
now if I took it just be you know five
or five right but then guess what
he's got the file right he's like oh I
got the D file now so I don't want to
give up the D file so so what's a good
move for me if I don't want to give up
the D file just slide my other rook over
I guess what we're operating like a
10-point piece now okay
they're very open yeah so so at this
point white needs to realize I have two
rooks coming down to d1 right I'm
threatening to take his rook on d1 so he
really needs to do something about that
unfortunately my opponent makes a very
dubious move he's like I'm going to take
my pawn back Antron your rook
but unfortunately for him my rook is
protected won two different ways and
this rook is only defended one way so
when I take his rook he takes my rook
and now I can just consolidate to an
easy victory Knights you can move
backwards Knight takes bishop and now
we'll just see how easy easy this is and
a long time viewers will love my next
move f6 all right because I want to get
my king up but I don't want to play up
five so I want to be as fast as possible
so look so look at how my King moved
okay instead of going one two three four
moves right I just move diagonally and I
cut the route in half Kings moves
fastest when they move diagonally okay
so I give them a big check to feel
pretty good so now I'm up attacking this
pawn and so be pretty easy and now what
I want to do here is create a passed
pawn a passed pawn is a pawn that you
know no pawn can either stop so there's
no pawn you know on its on its file or
it's two adjacent files so so I just
played g5 and so
takes takes and now I can well I'll get
to it eventually in order to create a
passed pawn in this position all I would
have to do is play here and so when he
takes takes this is a passed pawn
unfortunately his King would be able to
to capture it in time so I decided not
to do that all right but that's how I
could have created it I said I got an
idea
and so now we already plays g4 I want to
just have it protected and now I got a
passed pawn there and I'm gonna get to
passed pawns now and I give him some
checks okay so now he's threatened to
get his passed pond by playing pawn
takes a seven check so I can just take
it and everything is okay now give him a
big check if he goes here do you see how
we have checkmate here notice the king
is what's called stalemated right now
meaning he has no legal moves on the
board okay see how that King can that
move so if I would play something like
wait is it unfortunately if I played the
pawn up with check here we would remove
the defender so who else could give him
a devastating check in this position
this guy can't this guy can't we know
what happens if this guy does so who
else can give them a good check here can
Kings check each other go so by process
of elimination the night he goes up up
over and checkmate and yeah even the
computers all excited about mating
so it's very exciting and if he goes the
other way okay do you see how we have
checkmate in this position we actually
have two different checkmates believe it
or not so when a pawn gets to the
furthest rank and promotes to a queen
checkmate or you could even promote to a
rook in this in this instance but it
doesn't even want to let me do that so
those are different kinds of a
checkmates we have but the last thing we
would want to do in this position when
this King is stalemated like this is
move or a knight like here okay because
then it would be a stalemate and when a
stalemate occurs even though I'm up you
know three four five six to one the game
is a draw and we split the point cuz of
stalemate okay so so that's why you see
people playing on in what looks like a
lost position because they're going for
stalemate because they can still salvage
half a point yes they'll mate yeah if
this was the position you see how White
has no legal moves on the board he
cannot move his pawn he cannot move his
King and you cannot pass in chess so in
this case it would be a stalemate
deadlock yeah unfortunately and
unfortunately for for the player playing
black it would have been very bad
because he was crushing him the whole
game but then he got away at the end so
gotta watch out for those all right so
we got one more game here very
interesting game very interesting game
it's uh Jonathan or Thank You Britton he
was our beginner breakdown hero against
the same person Christopher and they've
played they played one house game in the
last tournament and now they did it
again at the AL
benefit okay so Jonathan has the white
pieces now okay so he starts out with
the Queen pawn okay and so now black
counters queen pawn okay
they're basically both trained to
control these you know he's controlling
a five he's controlling efore so if you
place something on e4 that's what I'm
just gonna take it
so now c4 so it looks very tempting to
take this pawn you like free pawn right
not really it's called a gambit okay so
you really don't want to be taking that
pond you want to be playing c6 that's
called the Slav variation of slob
defense that's a good way to protect
that pawn most grandmasters play e6 and
we don't need to know how to be as that
is because it blocks them the bishop
okay so but that's a variation you could
play all right so so black decides he's
gonna protect it with Knight f6
so now after he takes takes guess what
you don't have control of efore anymore
and I'm going to take it alright it's
always good to have a big center that
means your pieces can be flying around
while his are backed up you know so yeah
I always try to control the center now
this is a this is a check a lot of
amateurs love to play like you see this
position you see wow I have Bishop to b5
check that's not a good move because
unfortunately black can just play c6 and
now your Bishop has to retreat so if you
wanted to play like let's say I don't
know Bishop to e2 in this instance okay
okay
okay now it's uh that's his move okay
and let's just say for grins he decides
hey I want to play c6 and now it's
you're moving you got to develop another
piece but if you were like I'm playing
check and now he's like I'm gonna black
you and now Bishop e2 guess whose move
it is now it says Moo okay so so you
don't want to waste time and tempo by
playing that dubious check whenever they
can black with the C pawn you don't want
to play that check so let's see what
white Willie plays he plays Knight to c3
just developing pieces ye6 so he kind of
blocked in his Bishop here Knight f3 but
now he got Bishop to b4 attacking the
knight so now this Knight is in an
absolute pit it's stuck it cannot move
right or else the King would be gone so
now Bishop e3 just get more pieces off
off the row protecting the pawn so now
black gets castled white gets his Bishop
out so so that was good of Jonathan who
was playing white in this position he
knew we wanted to play as bishop well
well whatever
alright so Bishop to d3 so now so now
Christopher makes a mistake you should
never try to capture pin pieces you
should attack them okay unless you have
some kind of profit with this but by
taking this Knight this Bishop is worth
3 this Knights worth 3 I mean it's just
an even trade and he relieved all that
the pressure in the position so now
Queen goes the d7 which is not a good
good idea he has in ideas he needs to
start having us like let's get my knight
you know somewhere or let's just or
maybe 97 c5 maybe you know let's
something to get some room over here his
ideas not too hot
Queen d7 Castle and now he offers a
trade all right Queen for Queen and
Jonathan is like I do not want to trade
the Queens I'm going to attack your
queen instead so now queen the b5 now he
plays ePHI so so there's a sacrifice in
this position it's called the Greek gift
notice how this Bishop is on the same
diagonal as this pawn okay so so I'll
show you what the Greek gift is and show
you how it wouldn't actually work in
this position so Greek gift is when the
bishop comes down and takes h7 with
check okay so that's the position on the
board King takes and now you bring your
knight up to give them a big shock all
right and now the King goes back or to
g6 let's just say he goes back now we
put our queen on h5 and if he doesn't do
anything about this checkmate right so
it's a sacrifice to get what you want
okay sacrifice is like the Greek gift
and so forth work pretty well because
because if you look here like this is
the King side right look is there
anybody helping the King at all his
Knight his bishop the rook Queen they're
all on the Queen side they're not
helping him at all
and he's got one two three four and the
rook on the King side so checkmate
should happen but unfortunately the
Greek gift does not work in this
position hopefully the people there
sticking around can tell me why so after
I play a record he slams Queen h5
threatening Queen h7 checkmate what is a
really cool
way to defend the h7 square in this
position moves like g6 f6f-5 lose
instantly to a queen h7 checkmate and
don't even get me started on rook e8 or
d8 does lead to their catastrophe as
well so who could possibly get over
there knocking that over there but who
could possibly help out and protect h7
does Bensimon even know well
Queen d3 but yeah Queen d3 and now we
can just offer in the trade and if he
gives us double pawns we're like I don't
care we're up a piece I'll take all the
double pawns you want okay so that's why
the Greek gift does not work in this
position but he's like oh no not the
great gift so he's gonna play t6 just to
stop the Greek gift so now so now okay
so he made a compromise he had to move
one of his soldiers in front of his king
okay they're like football like the
offensive linemen okay you want them as
close to you as possible so they're
pushing you back okay but now this guy
is up so now people can can get around
them you know so so now Bishop h6
attacks the rook and you see how see how
Jonathan's ideas would be like Queen
here Queen here Queen here checkmate
that easy right
1 2 3 4 I don't know how he's gonna stop
that
but luckily Jonathan looking for him
Jonathan doesn't try that he decides to
get creative again with Knight up so
he's like I'm just gonna play my knight
up and see what happens I'm not gonna
try to develop any of these guys okay so
there yeah you need all the whole team
playing right that's why II six never a
fan
okay alright so he plays Knight takes h7
so King takes it and now can you tell me
which piece our pawn of blacks is
currently in a pin so you see this King
so one of these pawns are in a pin see
how this Bishop is coming down so this
pawn cannot move okay so you can just
you know humiliate the pawn essentially
and be like yep you can't get me so I'm
just gonna put something there and just
torment you okay and now now he's
threatening like if he would play a five
right a discovered check okay discovered
check we're the king yes yes yes you
have to be you have to be on the lookout
at all time because the forces are
coming against you fast all right so he
plays King to g8 so so the move in this
position was actually rook to h8 very
tough to see because every place check
now I'm I'm threatening you but luckily
you know he doesn't see it so he plays
King to g8 and now remember it's time to
just you know he's got nobody he
literally has nobody on the Kings side
now so now is a great time to sacrifice
so Bishop takes pawn pawn well pawn
doesn't even take because if pawn takes
Queen takes with check King only has one
spot and now do you see the checkmate
you can get really really close to the
king because Kings cannot capture
protected pieces so you see it
and you always want to check mate with
the power piece yeah you ever yep
checkmate
or you can just you million for a while
and then get checkmate you go you got so
many different checkmates okay right
Queen g7 check me g8 a fortunate
wouldn't work because Kings can capture
pieces then yeah that's right
it's very important that you know you
know if you're really close to the king
you got to have those pieces protected
so now so he decides not to take this
because he saw it would lead to mate so
he protects it with rook to f7 and now
he gets creative again and gives him a
check and so so now he moves alright so
let's see if we're gonna even play
better than Jonathan here okay okay so
so let's look at this we have three
pieces lined up on this h-file here okay
okay so so if you had just this thing if
we had two free moves right look we look
right now we could check made them on g8
now right because it's protected by the
bishop right so who do you think we
would want to move and where to make
checkmate on g8 a possibility it's white
to move and we want to check make the
black King and what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna give you two free moves you got
two free moves so I'm I'm gonna just I'm
well
I'm gonna guarantee you I'm gonna play a
five okay so whatever move you make I'm
playing a five and then you can get a
checkmate okay
so of these three pieces obviously the
rooks aren't gonna do it right okay so
if you play Bishop the g7 check would
move would I play I would just take it
right because it's not defended so this
move does not have to be a check we just
want to set up a checkmate here right so
who are these three pieces who's gonna
be delivering the checkmate do you think
the LightSquared bishop probably not
because the king is on a dark square the
lights crew are the dark square bishop
well if we had more than two moves that
that's that would probably be right but
we only have two moves are the most
powerful piece in the game the Queen so
are those three pieces who do you think
okay the Queen okay great
so so if you could place this Queen and
put her anywhere on the board just throw
her anywhere where would you want to
throw her right now a ga right that's
because that's checkmate
okay okay but unfortunately the Queen
you can't we can't just throw the Queen
so so what move will we have to play
with the Queen here g5 okay so let's say
we played Queen to g5 all right and I
lie to you all right
I'm not playing a5 I'm gonna take your
Bishop now I'm not gonna like Queen of
GA become a possibility are you upset
about that or you're like no big deal
because I've got another maid in mind
what's the other checkmate
Kings cannot capture protected pieces
right
Queen g7 right excellent Chuck may write
and make game over game over right right
that's now he learned how he learned
yeah that's the whole point yeah right
so so let's see how Jonathan Jonathan
doesn't see how great we are
so he's like he plays he plays Bishop
here and unfortunately Chris Brian
doesn't see that f5 could maybe save
them and so he just plays like Knight up
or here right where's where's this
position and now do you see a checkmate
notice if we move our Bishop here right
it's not going to be checkmate because
he can move to g8 right okay so so the
Queen doesn't have any checks well I
mean that they'll read to mate at least
but who can who can deliver a check in
this position who's the only other
player what and you can ask yourself
like what color is the King on black and
luckily we have both our bishops so who
do you think is going to be delivering
the big checkmate here
gee Bishop to g5 - we're about the f6
right yeah absolutely yeah and then
checkmate again yep so lots of cool
mates and yeah we're just I just just
work on some uh some made in twos made
in threes and you know you'll be going
from there so so there's a lot of fun a
very beginner lesson but uh that's what
we're here for it beginner breakdown